[Música]
olá meu nome é jamile eu tenho 10 anos e
vou falar um pouquinho sempre que eu sei
sobre a internet na vida das pessoas e
como esse hábito está influenciando a
vida das pessoas em seus relacionamentos
espero que gostem são uma criança e como
todos vocês
adoro usar a internet então por que
escolheu esse tema
escolhi esse tema pois entendo que o
vice está se espalhando com facilidade
pela nossa sociedade
essa vive em que dá dicas e conselhos
para vocês não ficarem viciados ou para
vocês ficarem atentos a esse exercício
a internet é muito importante no dia de
hoje
hoje quase todo mundo tem e precisa dela
no dia a dia mas é bom tomar cuidado com
o que você vê na internet ou com quem
você fala na internet pois muitas
pessoas ela para o bem e para o mal
ela já ajudou muitas pessoas mas também
consegue piorar a vida de outras muitas
pessoas que vieram assistir pensa que
sabe falar sobre coisas internet
sim a internet tem muitas coisas mas
também ela tem algumas coisas boas agora
você está alguns pontos positivos da
internet acesso fácil e rápido a
informações e interação com pessoas à
distância comunicação em tempo real
a globalização da comunicação
isso significa que antigamente era bem
mais difícil para chegar a um aviso uma
carta poder
a demora poderia descer dias semanas
meses e até mesmo anos
agora que a internet está bem mais fácil
como tinha falado a internet também não
tem só os seus pontos positivos ela
também tem alguns pontos negativos
agora você está
alguns pontos negativos da internet
redução do contato humano real pode
diminui a capacidade cerebral
o computador acaba pisando por nós
estamos sujeitos a notícia as faltas e
surgimentos de novos crimes
precisamos ter mais contatos
uns com os outros isso significa que
ultimamente tivemos uma família ao redor
de uma mesa todos como seu celular
isso que sim conversando com uma pessoa
celular e esquecendo de quem está ao seu
lado
isso ser humano está desenvolvendo um
probleminha que é ele está perdendo a
capacidade de escutar
ele só quer sem escutado deveríamos
viver em paz amigo colegas brincando é
conversando passeando e muitas outras
coisas gostosas que podemos fazer sem a
internet
você sabia
a internet pode causar sérios problemas
para você você pode estar pensando a um
simples aparelho não pode é causar nada
para mim e sim um simples aparelho pode
sim todas as séries problemas para você
você pode ter sérios problemas com sua
visão como eu tinha falado você perde a
capacidade de ouvir e muitos outros
problemas e foi peace em pensando no
tempo excessivo que as crianças estão
passando nos seus tablet e celulares que
eu vou falar algumas dicas é não deixe
de green card futebol boneca pega-pega
esconde-esconde e muitas outras
brincadeiras gostosas que podemos fazer
também não deixe de conversar com seus
colegas amigos e familiares até mesmo
não esqueça de ler esse daí ajuda a
nossa imaginação
também não podemos esquecer que não
essas crianças que estão passando muito
tempo provavelmente vocês também
agora eu vou recitar o poema que eu fiz
para vocês
a internet é boazinha mas também
perigosa tinha por isso não podemos
vacilar na hora de acessar
mas muito cuidado com quem você vai
falar
pois nem todo mundo quer te ajudar o que
mais te atrapalhar
então vamos usar a internet da forma
correta
espero que tenham gostado de tchau
[Aplausos]